hello world welcome upside to this video
playing the guitar yeah never really
scored well against him hmm what can I
do something else at the Trump mm-hmm
he's not playing this this opening
usually more of a mainline player anyway
um I'm totally okay with this this loyal
America Bishop g4 here instead of could
be six okay Quinn be six is not a
mistake it's just not entirely clear
that I need this Quincy too well maybe
it's just beautiful shouldn't be too bad
okay sorry for the noise I just got a
message on skype and that they had to
head to address okay huh you want to
draw no yeah I wouldn't wouldn't and I
wouldn't have taken the draw anyway but
sometimes you can can irritate a little
bit by repeating once or twice okay
let's just develop I took on a 3 i'm not
a huge fan of giving up my pair of
bishops as you probably can guess but in
this particular case there was no big
alternative the bishop can easily field
side light on g4 just taking it or
taking with it on c3 is a good and
simple choice here not quite sure what
what to do Knight takes on Bishop takes
it's probably another big deal the
bishop is good on his servants is why I
took with the norm of the Queen maybe am
indeed as a knight takes yeah Queen
takes of course what I meant so it looks
like we get some kind of endgame and
yeah I don't think I've got problems
here it's a he's got the bishops but
that's a very solid position so how to
play f6 and e5 would be would be good
good to get so I go 94 and to try for
that
d6 can also be helpful f6 this Bishop c4
I guess so let's go up to 8 k so Bishop
t6 now we'll get rid of the bishop pair
and it should be the equalizer f6 king
of 75 this is the typical way to
activate the Queen add the king it seems
fine yeah before but I really don't mind
to go to 85c for as a good and good
destination for the night attacking his
pawns
yeah i'd really like to score in this
game he completely completely really
killed me in the lives in a live stream
recently I really lost without any any
kind of chance so okay yeah my king is
far more active so this should be and
quite good for me a bit surprised that
he saw so willingly trades and now maybe
he has no big alternative but still
surprised k or king up Kingi 697 and
then he five here that's good
yeah that should be enough check winning
a three are winning be five
right today will look something I don't
think so no 93 King b6 does win check
hmm i actually did overlook something
where I can take right there is I can
just take it it's not a big deal i take
c 5 or what is he doing i can even check
then night a 5 check check this is much
better King like resign Knight c3 and
King see 496 I both I winner winner
clear piece then yeah i'm happy that was
a decent game from nothing much
happening position so on oh it's funny
hey I never played a draw against him
four wins eight losses now it's five
wins and eight losses okay so yet the
trauma here here would be one small
expecting Quincy to but rook we won and
of course playable and played here and
tween a four hmm that's surprising I am
that's in read to them I should have
thought a little bit here I played a bit
too quickly yeah I had huge time issues
in the game ahead against him the last
game had against him so maybe this was
why I was playing so quickly he is c4 is
a good move the idea is that Bishop has
to move of course and if he goes here
Bishop d7 is very awkward sorry and the
Queen has no square and I'm threatening
94 it's pretty awful
and if he goes here oops oh me too so c4
was great for black yeah this time he
avoided it yeah I decided to just get
rid of that bishop if you play Bishop e7
I was thinking 95 could be could be a
problem now that Bishop is kind of loose
them and if you try to play this
sometimes you can get into trouble here
that doesn't look very dangerous but
maybe antiques takes Bishop e7 and long
Claude castle short castles details
Queen takes NC for IRC for seems to be
bad but I didn't really see that night
before was strong attacking here and
taking the pawn next hmm okay that was
good so c4 was a mistake he probably
should have prepared that a little bit
yeah but I felt that this must be must
be equal ish and I went for that Bishop
f6 also is interesting but uh yeah it
good move Bishop d3 that's a good move I
cannot move this now as Bishop these six
route d6 check Bishop I'd 7 is kind of
embarrassing therefore Bishop here we
should be for Bishop t6 and here white
is a little bit better with the strong
bishop on your phone ok we had this
yeah p fact this is a move I don't like
b5 is giving up giving up squares and
you don't really have any particular
benefit meaning he wanted to go here but
it doesn't really help what is the
engine giving 97 and 95 for that also
makes lots of sense but c4 is not a bad
square techniques Teague's you create I
think this is very straightforward but
the same game is better for black I'm
surprised that the engine only gives
black 0.3 I thought there should be
already some kind of way to to win one
of the pawns but this is the stock fish
line yeah that's good he tries to or its
tries to the engine tries to keep me
busy yeah with with the defensive moves
yeah maybe this is maybe white can't
keep the balance but not with what he
played I think now around here it gets
very critical Bishop d3 is better and
this is this is given by the comp
probably intending some kind of counter
play so that was happening and here it
is more than critical yeah 94 wins but
it's diff that that will be almost
impossible to hold really a 3 is weak be
5s week making us better it's probably a
loss yeah and the engine gets some
lowers his evaluation by the second and
like as a winning advantage
ok so a couple of chances missed but I'm
still happy with a pretty clean win
thanks for watching